this block of stores was located at 84
Massachusetts Avenue across the street
from mi T's main entrance one of em I
t's many connections to public
television this is where Boston station
WGBH first one on the air in 1955 the
building had previously been the home of
a roller skating rink and the wooden
floor bumpy from years of moisture posed
a challenge for cameras dollying across
it and made creaking noises nonetheless
in the six years at the MIT campus
location wgbh alumni say this is where
many successful careers were launched an
important broadcast work developed
including simulcast on radio and TV of
Boston Symphony Orchestra concerts with
some early once taped at MIT s kresge
auditorium after a fire in 1961
destroyed the studio's WGBH moved to
other locations mit president james
Killian was a leader in the development
of WGBH and played other important roles
in the early days of educational
television including as chairman of the
National Commission on educational
television and later director of the
corporation for public broadcasting
hello I'm John Fitch MIT science
reporter in the 1960s John Fitch hosted
the Science reporter television series
broadcast produced jointly by MIT and
WGBH a pioneering effort at having
scientists explain their work to a
general audience the series was another
MIT WGBH connection which had been
encouraged by president Killian dr.
Harold Edgerton a professor of
electrical measurements in the
department of electrical engineering at
MIT a man who is both an inventor and a
teacher and internationally famous as
the father of modern high-speed
photography way it worked was that WGBH
called me and asked me if I'd be
would I like to try out for this MIT
science reporter program and I thought
yeah that sounds really interesting over
the next four years we did just about
100 half our programs mit is
relationship with WGBH came into play
again when in 2012 kresge auditorium was
host of an MIT produced performance
documentary next and orchestra of
students from one of the world's great
science and engineering universities a
film featuring the premiere performance
of awakening by the MIT wind ensemble
wgbh boston aired the program the
following year and it went on to win an
Emmy Award so in this part of the MIT
campus where WGBH had its start to where
the Stratton student center is now we
come full circle to remember where a
piece of broadcasting history was made
you